what's going on guys this is Rob we are
back with the Thor comics and the ending
to this story is absolutely insane oh my
God I'm so excited to find out what
happens next but let's let's just get
into it let's talk about what's going on
here this comes after the events of the
what's that Banner of War when you had
Thor and the Incredible Hulk fighting
each other make sure you guys check the
playlist down in the description you'll
find a link to all the modern Thor stuff
that we're covering right now but what
this does here is this initially
transitions over to the return of corvus
glaive as well as the a little girl
named lhasa I think is how you pronounce
her name lhasa l-a-u-s-s-a here's the
thing corvus glaive man this guy's like
a cockroach who just won't die like
literally he just won't go away man like
it's just he just he crops up all the
time now it's because he has like a
super advanced healing factor and Truth
to tell corbus clay was kind of the
standout star of Jonathan Hickman's
Infinity loss was relatively new so she
appeared not too long ago back in 2014
and the idea behind her is she is
actually the product of a relationship
if you want to call it that between
Freya and certain so she's actually the
daughter of Freya inserter as opposed to
the daughter of Gaia and Odin like with
the character of Thor but the thing
about this is corvus glaive his is
actually capturing laosa for a very
particular reason and so what he ends up
doing is once he has her in his
possession which is really just by
tricking her saying like we're gonna go
see your mom that kind of thing he
starts hopping and skipping through the
Realms and the reason why this happens
is because as most of you guys know
heimdall's been dead for a little while
right he's no longer the guy who sees
everything instead now it's Sif and so
the role of someone seeing everything
that goes on right the the comings and
goings of Asgard that's still there but
the way to escape that process is
actually by jumping around the Realms
and creating a very confusing Trail it's
very difficult to follow someone who's
done that especially if you're someone
like corbus glaive who knows how to
dodge the views of the different members
of the Asgardian race and so what ends
up happening here is of course once Thor
realizes what's going on what he's also
doing is studying a map of niflheim now
this is important because of the fact
that if you guys remember the video that
we did on Thanos his new origin Thor had
traveled to Saturn's moon Titan in order
to at the very least understand what was
going on with this Vision he received
from the Black Winter of course that was
during Donnie Kate's run again this is
all in the playlist so you guys aren't
going to be left out at all but
basically he saw a vision where Thanos
was wielding a wielding mjolnir with the
Infinity Stones attached to it he had
the the destroyer's glove along with a
black infinity stone we'd never seen
before and he was leading an army of the
dead right it was pretty nuts and so the
result of this is Thor's been trying to
figure out what all that means but once
he's told by Sith and everybody hey so
basically we have a situation where like
loss is gone your sister's been taken we
don't know where she is he ends up
traveling to visit a woman named Runa in
Cleveland Ohio of all places right the
mistake on the lake so the thing about
this is that Runa is a cool character so
to kind of fill in a little bit here
because I actually don't think you'll
find this in the playlist for Thor one
of the things that had happened here is
a long long time ago in a comic book
publisher Far Far Away called Image
Comics a guy created a character named
Angela from the Spawn comics angel was
the property of that guy I don't
remember what his name is but when he
left and came over to Marvel he also
brought Angela with him so in the old
story original sin what Marvel did is
they introduced Angela as the long-lost
sister of Thor who basically belonged to
the realm of Heaven that had been cut
off from the other nine Realms by Odin
and so once Angela came onto the scene
she was a horse honestly I think she was
more interesting in Marvel than she ever
was in the Spawn comics but the thing
about this is that during Angela's time
on Earth she ended up coming into
contact with a girl named Runa who
basically became her became her love
interest Runa was cool right Runa was
very very comparable to Angela in terms
of her capabilities truth to tell uh
Tessa Thompson's character of Valkyrie I
wouldn't be surprised if somewhere along
the line she's confined to the role of
being Aruna now Runa does have a really
cool history here and we'll talk about
it over the course of this but Runa is a
person that's very knowledgeable about
the realm of niffleheim in a way that
Thor simply just isn't and so what ends
up happening is Thor goes to visit her
and says tell me everything you know
about this place specifically this
mountain range in nipplehang right
because Thor's been to niffleheim it's
not like he's never been there before
and knows nothing about it but he
doesn't know everything about it and so
with this this mountain range that he's
not very knowledgeable about Ruta is
aware of it and what roona ends up doing
is basically becoming a sort of guide
for Thor now one of the things to
understand here is that Runa and Thor
are not necessarily friends and I mean
that in no uncertain terms they don't
necessarily get along all that well but
she was a valkyrie Once Upon a Time and
so she does on some level still hold her
allegiance to the throne of Asgard and
so what ends up happening is when Thor
asks her what's going on she starts to
Spill the history here so of course I'm
going to give you guys what she says
here but I'll also fill in the gaps in
terms of what's not covered here and so
what she says is that we were fighting
one of our grandfather's Wars fighting
and losing and it was a Slaughter now at
the time that she was a valkyrie she was
serving board the father of Odin right
so Thor's grandfather here and she says
Bohr's Sorcerers had a weapon that they
predicted would end the war end all wars
and make him God King of the Realms of
life and death but it went wrong there
was an explosion an eruption of Magical
Force wild and unpredictable though it
did successfully end the battle the
sorcerers could not stop the eruption
all they could do was seal it off and
contain it create a Zone where no one
would venture hide it behind the walls
of enchantments and spells because
anyone who stays too long becomes
contaminated now here's the thing to
understand about all this so when it
comes to the roles of The Valkyrie in
Marvel Comics they largely maintain the
role of shepherding the dad to the
afterlife right usually tavalhalla
occasionally there might be a bit of a
deviation there but that's usually
almost always the case right Warriors
who died in battle are taken to Valhalla
by the valkyrie themselves but the
valkyrie served the Throne of Asgard and
so one of the things that Marvel's been
doing here in recent years is that where
the valkyrie were kind of their own
thing that existed out there albeit
still subservient to Odin insofar as
anybody else was they were sort of
separate right like they played their
role and that was it and occasionally
Odin would call them in to have them do
stuff what Marvel's been doing in recent
years is they've actually been bringing
it closer in in line with the Marvel
Cinematic Universe which is kind of what
Marvel Comics has been doing right the
MCU does something and Marvel Comics
copies it as opposed to the other way
around and this basically led to a
situation where the valkyrie Now operate
as much as soldiers of the the Kings and
really the rulers of Asgard as they are
their own group that Shepherds the dead
and so what's really interesting about
this is that what she tells Thor is be
careful here in this place it's a place
of deception right it's a place of
trickery so when he asks like how in the
world do we get in there her response is
we have to go through the ice nothing
can prepare you or nothing I tell you
can prepare you for what you're going to
see but you have to understand here
under any normal circumstances you would
desire to swim to the light you have to
swim to the dark instead that's our way
in and so once they get in there and
they swim to the Dark Places and
ultimately wash up in this kind of
blocked off mountain range there's a
giant volcano in the middle of it right
like of course this Giant mountain range
looks like Mordor from Lord of the Rings
Where where Sauron was just sitting
there with a giant eye just creeping on
everybody but the cool thing about this
and this this is where it really really
gets interesting so as soon as they show
up onto the shore Runa continues her
story and she says we tried to move out
to move out all of our dead but we
quickly learned that we could not stay
in this place for long I never went
farther than this but some of my sisters
did the few who came back were not right
gondol came back addled confused and
foolish she was never the same Hoda
survived for a while but she lost her
Shadow and as time went on she simply
faded away now when Thor asked the
question about basically this girl
fading the response of roona is when she
came back it was like she came back as a
ghost right she wasn't a tangible being
anymore as she just sort of began to
disappear and that was basically it
right Allah began speaking to animals
she ran off to live in the forest but
most just never came back and so this is
a very dark and twisted place and so as
they're making their way through here
what they end up realizing is that
Shadows are kind of moving around
initially they think is tangible beings
but it's actually just the Shadows
themselves and because the Shadows are
descending on them it's like Thor
fighting Shadows of himself and so it's
really in a lot of ways the mountain
working against him now truth to tell
this is probably just a form of magical
enchantment is really all it is right
those individuals who show up here the
magic of the mountain conjures Shadows
of your own likeness and then those
Shadows try to kill you and then
probably in snare you right like take
your soul and then that's basically it
but Thor of course being as capable as
he is ends up using mjolnir to cast
lightning create light and then pushes
the Shadows away and so at that point we
basically switch back over to uh to
laosa and to corvus Clay now this is an
exceedingly important part of the story
so what ends up happening here is that
this mirror that they're looking at
basically seems to show the future and
so of course lost ends up seeing herself
in the future but when corbus glaive
sees himself he sees himself as a
conqueror and what that does is that
pushes them all the further in order to
unlock the mountain Secrets by basically
sacrificing some of the blood of Lhasa
in the process which he does a few times
but following that again we kind of
continue on with Thor and with Runa but
as they're making their way through here
one of the things that happens they come
across what looks like a cavern
effectively filled with some kind of of
molten material or something like that
but it's actually people's bodies who
are trapped in here and so as they're
making their way through they suddenly
end up coming across a disembodied voice
that both of them recognize and this
voice simply just says Let the Fire
cleanse them the ashes of men are but
the Shadows Of Life burn it burn them
all and they end up realizing the voice
is coming from boar himself now this is
when things really take off because I
imagine by this point you guys are kind
of like where's Thanos and all this he's
coming and he's coming right now so
here's what happens right like as this
is going on they end up realizing
they're looking into a kind of
projection right a sort of mirror not
the exact same one they saw before that
that uh lhasa was using but this one's
different it's actually kind of a time
Loop what ends up happening here is that
there is a valkyrie named brune who's
basically the leader of the Valkyries at
this point in time serving under bore
now the Valkyries themselves according
to Bruin her job is like we're supposed
to be shepherding the dead Warriors to
the afterlife but boar won't let them
instead vorte's them to get out onto the
battlefield end to fight and so where
she's very much really stands against it
vort chastises her and says like you
answer to me right you are my Valkyries
therefore you will do what I decree I
don't care about your responsibilities
to the dead their souls can wait this is
more important than all of that now
there is truth to what he's saying the
situation they're facing is incredibly
important and exceedingly dire but the
bigger thing about this is that it's
really kind of dishonoring tradition
it's bore taking it upon himself to
remove the valkyrie from an honorable
role which is considered honorable it's
like a desecration to refuse to allow
the Valkyries to take the souls of the
Dead to the afterlife and so that's when
really Runa kind of starts to figure out
the bigger picture that it wasn't as
though the Valkyries had turned against
their role and Allied themselves with
four it's that they were made to and so
in the midst of all this we end up
finding out that the foe that they're
facing off against right the battle that
they're fighting is a battle against
Thanos and in fact by and large it's a
one-man War like it's basically Thanos
by himself invading this round and
facing off against Sports now we don't
exactly know why but the exchange
between the two is phenomenal and I love
the way this was written so literally
Bohr says how like a mortal ever trying
to escape fate ever trying to claw their
way out of inevitable death
impertinently battling your station your
very nature and the response of Thanos
is how like a god to dismiss those they
deem beneath them to hoard power and
squander it with their lack of vision to
meet the concerns of those they rule
with insufferable silence after all what
would a God know about death and the
response of boar is let me show you and
it's just an amazing exchange between
the two I loved it but the battle is
Extreme right it is an intense battle
and so of course obviously Thanos not
fighting by himself but like Thanos with
his forces it might as well just be
Thanos by himself I mean it's one of the
things told you guys who are unfamiliar
with Comics one thing to know there's
Thanos and then there's who's whoever
he's leading but the forces of Thanos
are nowhere ever near as powerful as he
is but what ends up happening is when
Thor asks roona where are you in all of
this her response is I'm on the Western
Front right at this moment we are
recalled we're told the King has entered
the battle he's fighting a stranger one
who's killing friend and foe alike but
before we got there the mountain erupted
and when that happened everything went
belly up the echo kind of repeats itself
and then Runa just sort of Muses to
herself whether or not Thanos managed to
survive the whole thing and the response
of Thor is oh he absolutely did right
and so that's one of the things to keep
in mind this fight between war and
Thanos is happening in the far distant
past but remember Runa was basically cut
off from everything that was happening
in the multi in the Marvel Universe all
this time so by the time Runa returned
to the Marvel Universe right to the nine
Realms and everything Thanos had already
been killed so she didn't know that
Thanos had just like managed to survive
all of that and all those different
things I mean it depends on kind of on
the story that's being told right I mean
sure maybe she was walking around and
was like Hey Thor like you ever heard of
a guy named Thanos I remember fighting
him once upon a time he seemed kind of
strong right like was he strong yeah
roona he got a glove with some magical
stones on it and almost conquered the
universe how many of the dude could take
a punch you know I mean I don't know if
that kind of conversation happened but
nonetheless right you end up having Thor
and Runa that finally catch up to corvus
Glade and this is where the ending of
the story gets crazy so what ends up
happening here is that as they're
talking right and that's corvus glaive
makes his move and actually brings forth
drauger right basically the undead to
Thor and Runa in order to battle them
directly that what happens is you have
these kind of goldfish that start
swimming out of nowhere which are
basically Memories the dragger in turn
are hunting them and then of course Thor
and Runa are met by the drauger one of
the cool things about this and what
we're told here is that because these
things are memory drauger are born from
an unfinished business right like those
you guys ever saw Casper ghosts linger
around because of unfinished business
that's how the drawer exists in the
Marvel Universe I don't know if they
exist that way in the real life legends
that exist out there about drauger and
the stories and obviously drogger don't
exist but still like in those Mythos
stories here in the real world about
them I don't know the bases behind them
but nonetheless what the drawer do is
they feed on these fish believing that
they can somehow sustain themselves
right they can catcher you know capture
their right memories or the correct
memories or whatever and it's just sort
of the price they pay for having died
with unfinished business but the thing
about this is that once Thor and and
Runa get past them they face off against
the jogger directly they end up catching
up to corvus glaive and once they catch
up to him that's where the battle starts
to go nuts because one of the things
that happens here is that laosa as a
daughter of Serta can control fire Ash
molten lava all that kind of stuff so
she basically erupts the mountain right
like sends the mountain going crazy
which literally starts like a ticking
clock it's only a matter of time before
they gotta get out of there right like
literally Thor's uses the lightning from
mjolnir to conjure it into a physical
form and send it after uh after corbus
glaive now the crazy thing about this is
Thor's never really done this before
when it comes to Thor casting lightning
down it's just lightning bolts that
strike stuff and that's basically it but
the idea of him having the lightning
take on a tangible form and go after a
particular person that's never really
happened and so whether it's because of
the mountain or because of the fact that
Odin is now inside the the hammer at the
Spirit of Odin is within the hammer
itself and Thor's tapping into a level
of power he didn't know he had we're not
entirely sure as things go on we'll find
out of course in future Thor's stories
but it does allow him to take the fight
directly to corvus glaive and in doing
so the hounds kill corvus and his soul
is effectively locked inside the
building now right locked inside the
Mountainside and so what's nuts about
this and this is where this is this is
this is the ending that I was telling
you about where things go nuts Thor
himself needs to know what's going on
right Thor himself needs to know what's
behind the door that corvus glaive was
trying to get access to and because of
the fact that in essence lausa did not
really have the blood of boar in order
to make this happen that what ends up
going on is Thor Cuts himself and in
doing that the blood trickles down into
the pot and the door begins to open but
before we find out what's on the other
side instead we end up having this kind
of beetle right this Beetle that was
flying around and watching the whole
thing that's all it was doing right this
Beetle has just sort of been flying
around and fall following them the
entire time the beetle returns back to
its master and reports the news its
Master is none other than Dr Doom and
the only thing he says is at last what
this means I have no idea but if it's
enough power to Garner the attention of
Doctor Doom who's excited to grab it
it's got to be something significant so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end thank you all
for watching and I will catch you all
later
peace